[Musica]
perdonate in bio italiano e per rispetto
vostro io mi è stato permesso di parlare
in inglese
[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti come fa un super
robot a vivere i super robot sono noti
ai bambini tra tanti anni già
quarant'anni fa il robot si muovevano
per soldi
se chiedete un bambino di quattro anni
fa ma ho un robot a muoversi è facile lo
comanda actors dei costi gotri
raccomando hiroshi nel caso di jake e
nel caso del cannes ande mazinga lo
pilota la mente di tetsuya però questi
super robot erano incredibile non
avevano paura e thin man il dolore
sapevano cos'era e quando avevano
difficoltà lottavano e cadevano ma
sempre si rialzavano è sempre vincevano
ogni punta a terra anche noioso per che
vincevano sempre questo era mazinga
robot 40 anni fa era facile battere i
super robot si fanno a funzionare bar lo
stesso è sempre una mente umana che ti
guida da noi
io lavoro alla pet e 3 d pad va in 32
anni utilizziamo del robot per i tar i
bambini che lottano e che cadono a
rasarsi e magari vincere purtroppo non
posso portare le telecamere
dell'ospedale
perché per motivi di prove si allora
deciso di portare un robot qua per far
vedere come si fa a lottare a
controllare ispirarti un po una multi di
kit mistica e resistendo bene adesso
alza un pò così c'è scritto reggio
emilia siamo reggio emilia molto
interessante ho fatto un bel po di
strada si vabbe del resto vagamente di
tettoia tutto il resto fa duster e non
conosce la paura del dolore
cade si rialza sempre vincere
matura buonasera conta gente non ero
accordo con la città tutti ma la sera e
vi saluto che hanno facciamo ciao ciao
ciao ciao mi saluta ciao ciao ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
bene molto bene sono poi motion auto
scusate mi guardo da quella tra porto
che non ce la faccio a guardare il
pubblico in faccia non importa adesso
faccio un po di ginnastica mi giro però
mi sono vergognato e pensare che sono un
sacco di barzellette adesso dove rompere
il ghiaccio
prendete la confidenza con queste
persone ma reggio emilia perché sto
riguardando di moda reggio emilia regia
smettere tocco ci faccia la cartina che
che reggio emilia per me che sono qua a
bravo roberto ciao roberto peppe reggi
rieti sono quasi certo
cercavo proprio tetto doveva raccontare
una cosa fantastica
sai oggi a scuola ho preso 13 13 sì
veramente semplice ho preso due
matematica 4 italiano 3 geografia e 4 in
storia 13 beh guarda me è un po fesr
ditino guardi dal mio riguardo ti guardo
ti scruto beh buona sera a tutti mi
rigiro dall'altra parte allora è quindi
immagino saranno tutti scienziati
[Risate]
società tutti scienziati io sono un
sacco di barzellette ad esempio sapete
qual è il colmo per un professore di
matematica averi minuti compatti e non
mi fa ridere
non importa prova con un'altra prima
allora magari una sulla frutta verdura e
sai perché la carota non dorme perché
l'insalata russa e ford bordo di un
altro ancora allora c'è un pomodorino
che chiede al papà è vero che i bambini
nascono sotto i cavoli no tesoro li
porta la cicoria va bene sono abbastanza
simpatico sì che tutti simili
benissimo allora caro roberto seppe che
posso fare una domanda domanda molto
presente tu lo sai come fa un albero a
conquistare una pianta la corteggia te
lo fanno anche travolta
beh però so ho un po di cose se io sono
uno che si prende in giro perché ad
esempio tu lo sai la lingua che
parlavano gli antichi robot il penny
destino
no il latino infatti è colonna sport ha
preferito da un robot braccio di ferro
naturalmente credete beh noi ascoltiamo
su una musica heavy metal e questo si sa
e poi sai ci sono due mamme robot che si
incontrano dice una sai a mio figlio è
spuntato un dente di lap ho davvero in
via invece una salute di ferro bene cosa
mi racconti ten roberto un bene allora
grazie per meglio tarde papiro e
rilassato ero molto agitato primo ti
devi agitare ci sono invece sempre tanta
compagnia e tu quando hai bisogno basta
che chiami aspetta che mi faccia un po
di ginnastica
ecco così così a proposito io so fare
anche un sacco di giochi di magia
io sono questi di cg trici giocatore
aspetta sono uno spreco
insomma la magia i giochi di prestigio
vorrei avere un gioco di prestigio
allora guarda insomma metto le mani così
guardava guardate guarda le mani
guardami le mie mani mettendo un po del
suo guardare da lei adesso guarda bene
vedere sole giro così ea pro link judo
guarda bene vedi guarda guarda ancora
sparito però non fa ridere quanta gente
era un gioco di voi fatto spedire una
cosa che era già sparita sei solo oggi
sono in campo ingenuo vabbé roberto ok
allora io direi che adesso mi faccio un
altro bel sonnellino vi saluto tutti vi
mando un abbraccio un bacio a tutti i
fan di stretto stretto stretto e anche
tutti i bambini anche se qui oggi non ce
ne sono
ciao ciao
allora terzo pepper funziona così
importante di bambino che bene così e
sensato così invaghito da un robot teche
che palla che gioca che si dimentica
tutte le ansie le paure che ha così sta
accadendo anche a me per cui credevo
prima di novacella invece adesso che ce
lo sto per fare gli mostro il mio
certificato di rinascita non nascita e
rinascita perché io ho 26 anni quel seme
certificato di rinascita e la lettera di
dimissione dall'ospedale evidenza la
data che del 92 quindi ho 26 anni
anzi appena ho compiuto gli anni in
croazia più liguri il 29 agosto ho fatto
un grave incidente e sono entrati in
coma per fortuna ho fatto una buona
riabilitazione prima scherzando ho detto
il mio pezzo in italiano
vi assicuro che nel 92 italiano era
molto peggiore adesso vi faccio vedere
una cosa che non ho mai mostrato in
pubblico e che dà senso a questa questo
gioco che vi ho fatto assistere tratta
dalle note click della mia cartella
clinica il 15 di settembre 92 i medici
credendo che fosse ancora in coma
potete nato che c'è scritto coma post
traumatico hanno deciso di e sub armi
che stufare vuol dire che quando una
persona e rischio di vita di ben ha
messo un tubo nella gola per respirare
solo che restando lì 18 giorni saranno
formate del
delle ulcere che hanno reso l'estrazione
un po dolorosa e io il primo ricordo che
dopo il mio comma è stato proprio il
dolore pazzesco che prima nelle prove mi
commuovevo a pensiero di dover
raccontare invece vedo dei volti così
interessati così che invitano forze
voglia di raccontare racconto questo non
solo perché sono particolarmente
orgoglioso del mio percorso e perché è
un ambiente veramente familiare me lo
dicevano non ci credevo ma perché voglio
lanciare due messaggi
il primo è che c'è tanto bisogno di
testimonianze credibili
io ho sentito nei miei primi anni divide
rivita medici amici genitori che diceva
noi avete 93 che tutto passa di ritorni
a parlare un ottimo italiano che invece
quello che mi dava veramente la forza di
continuare a ripetere altre persone che
ce l'avevano fatta e per i bambini vi
assicuro che avere un amico in pediatria
che li aiuta che condivide coloro
anemico empatico alla loro altezza
perché bambini con problemi che hanno
importi quando vedono un medico un
infermiere o alto non parlano di 21 voti
invece per per la capacità di sciogliere
i sassi è veramente queste due cose sono
molto importanti e come importante fare
di tutto per di mi metterà 0 dolore in
ospedale soprattutto il dolore patetico
anni fa si diceva è normale che un
bambino bianca che un bambino soffre e
addirittura i donati venivano operati
senza essere sedati si diceva tanto il
bambino normale di piangono
invece adesso si sta capendo che dolore
soprattutto in età pedate ca passo
dottamente scoppito non ha nessun senso
[Musica]
frase finale è molto break edito mila
anni fa dove editor lo ripeta ticos e
nei canoni a parlava lui diceva che i
dolori lievi consentono di parlare di
dolore grandi rendono moti e questo è e
purtroppo verissimo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]